only thing that I'm going to say other
than that is this Charles boley's
looking over here he's staring over here
looking for what we saying you better
watch your mouth you know I'm coming
over there for you tonight you better
watch your mouth I'm telling you right
now be careful what you say I was going
to say I like that outfit you got on I'm
not going to lie but hey you know I was
talking to wge W said Halbert is playing
so good James Harden wanted to be traded
to
Indiana man boy wow that would be that
would be listen did did w know you were
going to quote him
probably that would be the first report
that I know of that w got wrong because
Indiana and James Harden don't go
together sorry sorry Chuck and Steven
doing on his ARG let's just make it
official Chuck versus stepen a May 18
May May
18th you know he's in trouble he's in a
world of trouble he's in a world of
trouble they should have never let you
come to B they should have never let you
come to B Hey listen I've seen Stephen A
on on Instagram in his
boxing can we get a clip as his boxing
video got to find
box that was that was that was 5 years
ago when a bad Rotator Hey listen we
know you we know you can box but you
definitely know Nolan Ryan when they
come out to throwing out the first
pitch w
oh sort of like you
[Music]
golfing can we see that footage for we
got have that footage somewhere come on
man come on ESP yall got to show him
first we got to hide it they looking out
for their brother I don't know if we I
don't know if we have that footage but
we do have footage uh Stephen A of Shaq
being on our Tuesday night show uh
sporting this hairstyle that's my stepen
a look
yeah I got it I got it see you I'mma
bring it back next week let me see that
again let me see it again what you doing
I don't it out let me see it again let
me see it again I got you I got you all
I'm going to say is this I I got a
couple of hours to prepare to get at
y'all stay I'll see you soon I'll see
you soon hey don't don't over prepare
okay the hair gu Bob Myers over here I
mean just taking all this in Ernie I'm
not sure whether or not we have time to
to get into the second game that you all
have on TNT tonight but take goad you
guys about basketball I don't know if
they talk about basketball well Bob you
and I can try as we we sort of redirect
here uh Ernie I know you usually do the
Neato stat of the night presented by no
one but I thought we would try our hand
at it because Zion Williamson is doing
something pretty impressive only
Shaquille O'Neal has average these sorts
of numbers in the paintt so Shaq what
are you expecting from Zion tonight I
would like Zion to say tonight listen I
know LeBron's here I know ad is here but
Vegas belonged to me tonight I'm a young
player these guys are getting older I
want him to go out and get
40 listen LeBron is the king ad is great
I know they playing against the Lakers
but in order to be the master sometimes
you got to kill the master so I want to
see Zion that Master ain't ready to die
Malica he's not ready to die
can I say something about what Shaq just
said I guess Shaq and I agree with him
about Zion but damn it I want to see
Anthony Davis too how about that you
healthy you in the lineup what you going
to do cuz we know Zion coming we know
New Orleans coming if Zion is healthy in
the lineup New Orleans can get to the
Conference Finals what you going to do
about it Anthony Davis you got a 39 yeld
in the 21st season playing better than
you and reli and being more reliable
than you what are you going to do about
that good point well you know you know
Stephen A what's crazy people forget
when Zion was healthy last season the
Pelicans had the best record in the west
that's right so the only the only
question about the Pelicans is Zion's
health and you know he says he's healthy
I'm really looking forward to seeing him
play in person I've only seen him a
couple times on television I'm really
and listen Shaq has a point when you're
a great player or want to be a great
player when you get a chance to play
against a LeBron James it's a big deal
so I'm looking forward to Brandon Ingram
and Zan play tonight and I'm looking
forward to two or two because the love
child of Charles Barkley and Shaquille
O'Neal Zion Williams is right here this
is your love CH this is the first first
time you get to see him career no worthy
game of Zion's career tonight I agree
with Shaquille this is about Zion he not
Anthony Davis Stephen A Zion is the
person we want to see is he ready to
emerge is this a coming out party night
for Zion it should be so since we don't
have any basketball players over here
you guys got all of them would you guys
have liked to play in this H how would
you guys have liked to play in this
thing barbecue chicken
alert I'm getting
45 who guard me a I'm getting 45 without
the free throw tonight hey Bob Myers you
know what you know we talk you know how
much respect I got for you I just want
to welcome you to stealing money on TV
like the rest of us
hey and also I want to give you credit
for jumping off the Titanic before it
sunk com I'm staying Lake I'm no no no
no no I have shot fir I have friends
over there yeah you going to see them
soon he might not he might not they may
be under water couple more things couple
more things in this segment mikica this
for you uh number one you go ahead and
use the term Neato stat of the night all
you want cuz it was is actually a stat
which it rarely is when I use it and
number two uh you have Michael wilbon I
do I have Charles Barkley this is true
who do you think drops more
names ohu oh good for a double double on
that I knew Chuck back then too he hey
hey hey one thing I look at that picture
I think man money make you look better
don't
it hey money make you look better two
for two CH hey money make both of look
better will I like them sideburns will
got them pork CH sideburns will going
over there that was only the 70s
K got them pork chops looking like
Reggie
Jackson thanks you all for coming on the
show was our pleasure to have you love
you this is T Johnson you guys T Tex
Johnson looking for stop stop it stop
it so what's the date for this May 18th
May 18th charlesy versus stepen a here
in Vegas May 18th
pay-per-view and tex Johnson will be
there